for most of the problems we will be  facing in the next few weeks we will  only need to work in two dimensions we  use a 2d coordinate system so we can  formally put vectors on a grid and more  easily do these vector operations once  we have our axes the next thing we need  are unit vectors unit vectors have a  magnitude of 1 and are in a defined  direction for our normal XY coordinate  system we have I hat in the positive x  direction and J hat in the positive y  direction in Cartesian coordinates the  unit vectors are the same no matter what  point in space we're at  we can also define a unit vector in the  direction of an arbitrary vector the key  here is to make sure it has a magnitude  of 1  you